- Legal Eagle is coming in loud and clear
thanks to Ting Mobile.
Today we're talking about
♪ Oklahoma ♪
- Where the wind doesn't
come sweeping down the plain
and the waving wheat does not smell sweet
because it appears that
Oklahoma is no more.
Is it possible that the Supreme Court
gave away half of the state?
Well, in what some people
are calling legal insanity,
the Supreme Court in the immigrant cases
decided that Native-Americans
still have reservations
in most of Eastern Oklahoma in
an area that includes Tulsa.
The Supreme Court says that
Native-American reservations
have jurisdiction over some of the crimes
that happen in that huge
swath of Eastern Oklahoma.
And Justice Roberts is warning that
this is just the tip of the iceberg,
that perhaps all of the
laws may eventually fall
under the reservation jurisdiction
and no longer be part of Oklahoma.
So the question is,
did the Supreme Court just
give away half of Oklahoma?
(soft music)
Hey Legal Eagles.
It's time to think like a lawyer.
Because if you live in Tulsa, Oklahoma,
you might be wondering whose
laws you have to follow
and who you have to pay your taxes to.
But some of the more fundamental questions
are what is a Native-American reservation?
And how does that impact
the laws that apply
in a given geographical area?
And does Eastern Oklahoma
belong to the state of Oklahoma
or other Native-American reservations?
Or did Oklahoma ever in fact
exist as a state itself?
(indistinct)
Well, the bombshell decision
of McGirt versus Oklahoma,
delves into the interplay
between state law
and the validity of
land rights established
by treaties granted by the US Government.
With some, including
the descent contending
that this decision will
upend governance in Oklahoma.
And I've had many people ask
what this case is really about.
And you would think that a decision
that begins with the words
"On the far end of the trail
of tears was a promise"
will surely find its way into
case law books in the future.
But this was a five, four decision
that's even more interesting
because the author of
the majority opinion,
Justice Neil Gorsuch broke
with his right leaning cohorts
on the Supreme Court.
And of course it gets
even more interesting
with multiple descents
with Clarence Thomas
writing his own descent
because more often than not,
Thomas can't even agree with
the majority of the minority
in its entirety.
So without further ado,
let's break down the incredible case
of McGirt versus the state of Oklahoma
and find out what's going on here.
So this case starts with the conviction
of one named Jimcy McGirt.
Which of course is the most
Oklahoma name you've ever heard
in your entire life.
And McGirt was found guilty
of three sexual offenses
and sentenced to life in prison in 1996.
He challenged his conviction
on the basis that the Oklahoma State Court
lacked jurisdiction to prosecute him
because he's an enrolled member
of the Seminole nation of Oklahoma
and his crimes took place on
designated reservation land.
And if indeed that's
true that McGirt's crimes
took place on reservation land.
Then he should have been
prosecuted in Federal Court,
not Oklahoma State Court
under the Major Crimes Act.
The deciding factor
for purposes of the Supreme Court analysis
was whether the land
given to Native-Americans
and treaties by the US government,
remains an Indian reservation
for purposes of federal criminal law.
Now, before we dive into
the specific arguments
by both the petitioner
and the state of Oklahoma,
I think it's important to
provide some history here
because that backdrop
informs this particular case
and explains why these treaties
existed in the first place.
Most remember in middle
school history class,
learning about what is
commonly referred to as
the "Trail of Tears"
And here's a quick refresher.
The 1830s Native-Americans
occupied large tracks of land
in states such as Georgia,
Tennessee, North Carolina,
Alabama, and Florida.
They resided on this land for generations,
of course, long before Columbus,
the Pilgrims or the Mayflower
because of the viability of this land,
white settlers wanted to
use their land for farming.
So in 1830,
president Andrew Jackson
signed the Indian Removal Act,
which gave the federal
government authority
to exchange this land
held by Native-Americans
for land out West in an
Indian colonization zone,
which is now present day, Oklahoma.
Faced with an invasion
by the US government
and all of the atrocities
that we know go hand in hand with that
the Native-Americans
left behind their homes,
which were alluded while they
were forced to journey on foot
to the land in Oklahoma,
without any supplies or
assistance from the government
that was kicking them out.
Thousands of Native-Americans
lost their lives
on this forced expedition,
which is why one tribal leader
accurately referred to it as
"a trail of tears and death."
4,000 people died on the trail of tears.
Now, while the main issues involved,
whether there is a reservation
or if it was just established by Congress
and what that means.
It's important to know
why this determination
has such a significant impact.
In 1885, Congress passed
the Major Crimes Act,
which places certain crimes
committed by Native-Americans
in Native-American territory
as subject to federal
not state jurisdiction.
It states that within quote
"the "Indian Country",
any Indian who committed
certain enumerated offenses
against the person or
property of another Indian
or any of that person
shall be subject to the same law penalties
as all other persons committing
any of the above offenses
within the exclusive jurisdiction
of the United States."
The MCA defines quote "Indian Country" as
"all land within the limits
of any Indian reservation
under the jurisdiction of
the United States government,
not withstanding the
issuance of any patent
and including rights of way
running through the reservation.
So the determination of
reservation or no reservation
is the difference between
some crimes being adjudicated
by the federal court,
as opposed to the state court.
So let's turn to the issues
that were at issue in
McGirt versus Oklahoma.
The first question is
did Congress establish
a Native-American reservation
in the first place?
If there was no reservation established,
then the petitioner's entire
argument would be moot.
State law, not the federal MCA
would be the controlling law.
The majority opinion concluded
that McGirt was right.
That Congress did establish a reservation
for the land in question.
Large swaths of Oklahoma.
To arrive at this conclusion,
the court had to scrutinize
the original treaty
with the group known as the Creek Nation
that was ratified and
enacted into law in 1833.
The treaty in no uncertain terms declared
the parcel of land that they were giving
in what is now located within Oklahoma
to be a quote "a permanent home
to the whole Creek Nation of Indians."
The treaty even spells out how
they would accomplish this.
The United States, it
provides would quote,
"grant a patent in fee simple
to the Creek Nation of Indians
for the assigned land."
To continue, "so long as
they shall exist as a nation
and continue to occupied the country
hereby assigned to them."
Within these lands, the
creeks were to be secured
in their unrestricted
right of self-governance
with full jurisdiction over
all enrolled tribe members
and their property.
This treaty, though many
Oklahomans aren't happy about it
is not really ambiguous.
It clearly defines the
large swaths of area
that fall under this treaty
and become a Native-American reservation.
So the next question is,
does the reservation still exist today
or has it been disestablished
by a subsequent congressional acts?
And the majority opinion
notes that over the years,
Congress has violated
its treaty obligations.
And this initially undivided land
is now fractured into various portions,
held by tribe members and
unaffiliated members alike.
Nevertheless, the court
opinion notes rather strongly
that the federal treaties and statutes
are the Supreme law of the land
and that it's up to
Congress and Congress alone
to decide if it wants to
breach those treaties.
The point being that only Congress,
not the states and certainly
not the judicial branch
can explicitly disestablish
the reservation.
This reminder of the importance
of separation of powers
among the three branches of government
has been flashed out
in countless opinions,
as well as Saturday morning
episodes of Schoolhouse Rock.
♪ Ring one, Executive ♪
♪ Two is Legislative, that's Congress ♪
♪ Ring three, Judiciary ♪
♪ See it's kind of like my circus ♪
♪ My circus. ♪
- But in writing the opinion
for the majority Justice Gorsuch,
summed it up pretty well saying that,
"Legislators might seek
to pass laws that tiptoe
to the edge of disestablishment
and hope that judges facing no possibility
of electoral consequences themselves
will deliver the final push,
but wishes don't make for laws
and saving the political branches
the embarrassment of
disestablishing a reservation
is not one of our constitutionally
assigned prerogatives."
Recall the Gorsuch is a textualist.
He looks to the text of the various laws,
and while he might not agree
with what the law says politically,
if he thinks that the text
militates a certain outcome,
that's the way that he is going to vote
on the Supreme Court.
And the bottom line is
that this is on Congress.
And if they want to
disestablish the reservation,
they need to do it explicitly
without getting the courts
to do its dirty work.
But that's not the end of the inquiry.
Because the question remains,
did some sort of
subsequent act of Congress
actually disestablished the reservation?
Oklahoma actually claimed that Congress
did disestablish the land
within the reservation,
starting around around the 1880s.
As a result of the rationally
authorized Dawes Commission,
the tribes were pressured to abandon
their customary communal living
and issue out individual
tracks of lands to its members.
Both the General Allotment Act of 1887
and the Creek Act of 1901
encouraged Creek members
to divide up their lands.
This eventually resulted in
some individual tribe members
selling their land to non
Native-Americans as well.
But according to the majority,
this was nothing like an
actual act of Congress
disestablishing the entire reservation.
Prior Supreme Court cases
already had held that allotment
is completely consistent
with the continued reservation status.
Moreover, as we talked about
the language of the treaty itself
also made this clear by
defining "Indian Country" as
"all land within the limits
of any Indian reservation,
not withstanding the
issuance of any patents,
and including any rights-of-way running
through the reservation."
In other words, the treaty
provides for the land
to be encumbered and divided in a way
that doesn't affect the
overall reservation itself.
And to drive the point home,
the court provides an analogy
that shows that fallacy
of equating allotment.
In other words,
dividing up the land to disestablish it,
getting rid of the reservation entirely.
The federal government has
issued its own allotment
to the form of what are called patents
that transfer legal title
to homesteads in the West.
And no one is going to argue that
the United States
sovereignty over the land
that they gave these homestead patents to
is in any way diminished because
of these particular acts.
And the same holds true
for the land buying the Creek Nation.
The plan might have been
to go from allotment
to disestablishment of the reservation,
but Congress never followed through.
And so the reservation still exists.
And although Congress took other actions
that impacted the Creek
Nation's reservation status,
like abolishing their tribal courts
and transferring all
of their pending civil
and criminal cases to
United States courts,
the Supreme Court has held
that none of these acts
disestablished the reservation itself,
even what's called the five
civilized tribes act of 1906,
which took away more of
the Native-American rights
stomped short of actually
disestablishing the reservation,
the Creek Nation still retained
their tribal government power
to do such things as collect taxes,
operate schools and legislate
through tribal ordinances.
However, arguably the strongest evidence
that the court provided was that in 1936,
Congress authorized the Creek Nation
to adopt a constitution and bylaws,
which actually restored powers
that they had previously been deprived of.
And to give you a little idea
of what the government now looks like,
it contains three separate
branches of government,
much like the US government generally,
a democratically elected principal chief,
its own police force, hospitals,
and an annual budget of 350 million.
So in other words,
the Creek Nation still exists.
And so does the reservation
in most of Eastern Oklahoma.
Now that said Oklahoma and the descent
trying to use circumstantial
and the land's demographics
as evidence of disestablishment.
In defending their position,
Oklahoma suggested a three step process
to determine disestablishment
where the court,
A, reviews the laws passed by Congress.
B, examines the contemporary events
at the time these laws were passed
and C evaluates subsequent
events and demographics.
In laying out this approach,
Oklahoma and the descent,
point out that state's ongoing practice
of prosecuting Native-Americans
located in "Indian Country"
for over a century,
as well as the massive
influx of white settlers
into the Creek Nations
lands over the years.
And they also point to various statements
made during the allotment era,
including those from the Creek Nation.
That seemed to indicate that
most believed the reservation
was on his last leg and in the process
of being disestablished.
But the majority's
response to this argument
is basically thanks
for the history lesson,
but that's not dispositive.
It doesn't matter.
Well, the court didn't deny
that the context can be useful.
It's only useful if the court
is interpreting ambiguous statutory terms,
which is a common Canon of construction.
When you're dealing with a language,
whether it's a statute or a contract,
if you have a contract dispute
and two parties want different things
and you look to the contract
and it's absolutely crystal clear,
then there's no reason to then think about
what the parties might have
said in negotiating the contract
because the contractual
language in this case
is perfectly clear.
But if the contract isn't clear,
then you're going to have to look at
what's called parole evidence,
evidence outside of the
four corners of the contract
to determine what to do.
And that's what the court is doing here.
And as far as the court was concerned,
there weren't any ambiguous terms here.
The treaty might be old,
but the terms were clear.
And as the majority pointed out,
Oklahoma and the dissenting
justice identify any cases
where these kinds of
extratextual considerations
led to the disestablishment
of a reservation.
So that takes us to Oklahoma's final
sort of last ditch argument,
which actually the dissenters
in this case seized upon.
And it's what we attorneys
call a policy argument.
A policy argument is designed
to appeal to common sense
by highlighting the real world impact
that a legal ruling could actually have.
These types of arguments rely more
on the factual implications of a ruling
rather than the actual statutory language
or constitutional framework.
And in this case,
the argument went something like this.
If the court decides that
the reservation exists today,
then one of two things
could potentially happen.
One other similarly situated tribes,
pre-existing treaties,
will claim that their
reservations still exist
as well with all the rights and privileges
that go along with that.
Number two and more to the point,
this decision would destroy
both the numerous convictions
that have already been doled out
as well as their ability
to prosecute future crimes
on Native-American reservation land.
And in the past,
these kinds of policy
arguments have actually worked
to shoot down Native-American
claims on their own land,
but here are the majority
wasn't having it.
First they point out
that the MCA is limited.
It only applies to certain types of crimes
and B it does not apply to cases involving
non Native-American victims or defendants.
And the court also shoots
down on the claim that
the sky is falling by reminding us that
the population of the area
only consists of 10 to 15%
of Native-Americans,
and many convictions
would not be challenged
because of the limitations
on post conviction review
and a desire to not roll
the dice in federal court.
After all, just because you're
not supposed to be tried
in state court doesn't mean you get away.
It just means you're tried
in federal court instead.
And above all Justice Gorsuch
rejected histrionic claims
saying that we proceed
well aware of the potential
for constant conflict around
jurisdictional boundaries,
especially ones that have gone
unappreciated for so long.
But it's unclear why
pessimism should rule the day.
With the passage of time Oklahoma
and its triumphs have proven that
they can work successfully
together as partners.
And one of the things
that's really interesting
about this particular
case is you get a sampling
of the kinds of arguments
that you see in a lot of
different Supreme Court cases.
Some argue from the original text,
some argue from the context
in which laws are passed
and some just flat out reject all that
and just argue from the policy arguments.
But it's interesting to see what worked
in this particular case and what didn't.
But finally we get to why you
probably came to this video
in the first place.
What are the implications
of this potentially momentous case?
Well in general,
this is an important decision
because first of all,
Gorsuch's opinion was
seen as an acknowledgement
that often Native-Americans
have been promised many
things by Congress.
And those promises have
generally not been held up
and here Gorsuch and the majority
are holding Congress's feet to the fire
and making them follow through
with what was originally promised,
even if it was promised over 100 years ago
or rather over 200 years ago.
And although Congress has
diminished and restricted
different tribes authority on
their reservations severely,
the reservation still exists
until Congress says otherwise.
And of course, Congress can say otherwise.
And at the heart of this
battle is a fairly arcane law
that deals with simply
who has jurisdiction
to actually prosecute crimes.
Here "the MCA applies to
Oklahoma on it' usual term saying
that only the federal government
and not the state may
prosecute Native-Americans
for crimes committed in Indian Country."
Of course, the larger question is
whether this decision
in the words of Ted Cruz
gives away half of Oklahoma.
But really the practical
implications of this decision
are not that dramatic.
The case does not change
any land ownership
in Eastern Oklahoma.
Oklahomans are not going to be forced
to abandon their homes
and walk a thousand miles
in search of a new home.
The decision also does not grant
the tribe criminal jurisdiction
over Non-Native Americans.
But it does mean that state
prosecutors lack of authority
to pursue criminal cases against
Native-American defendants
in parts of Oklahoma, that
includes most of Tulsa,
the state's second largest city.
But in fairness,
there's a lot less unresolved.
The majority decision
left open the possibility
of other impacts between
territorial rights
and taxation and other
jurisdictional issues.
But the court felt that Oklahoma
and the Native-American tribes
could resolve these things amicably.
It's unlikely that anything
dramatic is going to happen.
After this decision,
the state and five tribes
issued a joint statement,
stating that "The nations and the state
are committed to implementing a framework
of shared jurisdiction
that will preserve sovereign interests
and rights to self-government
while affirming
jurisdictional understandings,
procedures, laws, and regulations
that support public safety, our economy,
and private property rights.
We will continue our work confident
that we can accomplish more together
than any of us could alone."
So even if you live in Eastern Oklahoma,
it's unlikely that your day to day life
is going to be affected very much.
And if you live in Western Oklahoma,
and you're trying to get ahold of a friend
in Eastern Oklahoma you'll
want a cell phone service
that works in both,
regardless of whether Eastern Oklahoma
remains a part of the state.
And Ting Mobile is just the
cell service to reach the state
formerly known as Oklahoma.
Ting provides great LTE coverage
because it uses the T-Mobile
sprint and Verizon networks.
So you get the benefit
of three massive networks
wherever you go,
no matter which part of
the state you live in.
Ting Mobile is a different
kind of mobile provider.
With Ting you only pay for
the actual data and services
you use at the end of the month.
And because you're paying for
only what you actually use,
Ting customers pay on
average is $23 per month
for one device.
And with Ting, you can
use almost any cell phone,
including the newest
iPhone and Pixel phones.
And you can use the same phone number
you're using right now.
There's no contract overage fees
or any other carrier tricks.
You just pay a fair price
for the talk, text and data
that you use every month.
And ting has award-winning
customer service.
Because they don't have any
brick and mortar stores.
They pour all their
resources into their phone
and online support.
If you have any issues,
you can just give them a call
and you'll immediately
talk to a real human being.
Ting is an especially good deal
if you're around WiFi all the time,
which of course, most of us are
because we're working from home.
Because you aren't actually using any data
on the cell service.
You're just using your Wifi.
So you'll end up paying way
less than you do right now.
And Ting gives you the option
to pay only for what you use.
And if you go to LegalEagle.Ting.com,
you can use your last bill to compare
just how much you would save.
And Legal Eagles will get a $25 credit
by going to LegalEagle.Ting.com.
And that could cover your
entire first month of service.
So just click on the
link in the description.
And since there are no contracts,
you can try it for a month.
No strings attached.
Again, all you have to
do is click the link
in the description
or go to LegalEagle.Ting.com
and get a $25 credit for
whatever service you want.
Plus clicking on that link
really helps out this channel.
So do you agree with my analysis?
Are you mad that you watched
20 minutes of click bait
about a dry Supreme Court case
that probably won't have
much real world effect?
Leave your objections in the comment.
And check out this playlist
with all of my others real law reviews
talking about all the crazy stuff
that's happening with
the protests, COVID-19
and basically all of the news.
There's a lot of it.
So click on this playlist
and I'll see you in court.